oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Musique]
en
oh
[Musique]
tu connais dimon qui vient du bronx il
faut que tu lui apprennent tous les
trucs d'un bon lap dance à ok ça s'est
montré qu'ils mentent mac et alain tu
veux être indépendante jeu juste pouvoir
aider ma grand-mère faire un peu de
shopping de temps en temps c'est sale
type de wall street fait les boire assez
pour qu'il soit revu leurs cartes de
paix dit joker
mais pas trop pour qu'ils puissent
signer on n'a rien fait de mal rock avec
moi des tiers il est noir
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs tony vous laisserai pas faire
thiers jules prévenir mais qui lui a
rendu son portable
quatre étapes
[Musique]
vous en êtes
nos portables sont devenus
indispensables nous appeler gère nous
rendez vous notre santé notre vie
sentimentale
mais si une appli pouvait vous dire
combien de temps il me reste 63 ans 57
ans il vous reste à vivre
voudriez-vous savoir
quoi toujours cette appli est les bidons
c'est évident ma copine disait pareil ça
prébois tout
cette appli savait qu'elle allait mourir
[Applaudissements]
ce qui nous arrive
je crois que c'est à cause de cette
appli je veux tout changer changer de
portable de numéro et d'opérateurs vous
avez besoin d'autre chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'application
c'est l'affichage aléatoire d'un nombre
une horloge faut pas flipper pour ça
j'ai comme l'impression vous vous êtes
fait avoir c'est la liste de tous ceux
qui ont téléchargé l'appli elle la
télécharger
tout ce qu'on a à faire
ces deux pensées l'horloge d'une seconde
est ce que tu as déjà réussi à faire ce
genre de choses non mais j'ai beaucoup
lu à ce sujet si ça marche pas une
malédiction bien pire que la mort vous
poursuivra
je suis moi on vous accablera
il finira par vous détruire
réveille toi qu'est-ce qu'il ya tu m'a
appelé
[Musique]
à gauche combien de fois je dois te le
répéter tu lèves et moi mesdames
j'ai apporté mes visites pour aider à
mettre en place cette fête de l'eau ce
soir ça va être vraiment épique
coué l'alcool
mais à meilleure fête de l'année je vais
pouvoir tout mal et perd peut pas couper
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'y vais
c'est une très mauvaise idée
pourquoi tu veux y aller mais qd a déjà
regardé l'histoire de cette maison
des gens ont été tués ici beaucoup
dow s'est moqué des mois
la famille qui vivait ici lunettes on
doit y aller ouvrez la porte
ou est-ce qu'on est la maman chez pas
trop ma chérie et voir
[Musique]
désolé d'entrer chez vous comme ça
vous avez de la veine j'ai soigné plus
d'une morsure par ici je vais l'aider
[Musique]
ça a l'air complètement tari ça peut
être du tout c'est à dire qu'on a failli
la perdre ce qui a été fait pour votre
fille a un certain prix
son âme a été épargné vous devez
désormais en fournir une autre en
échange
sans quoi la sienne nous appartient mais
ce doit être fait avant le coucher du
soleil donc vous avez intérêt à ne pas
trop traîner
vous pouvez choisir l'homme que vous
voulez
mais ce doit être une âme humaine
vous apprêtez à tuer quelqu'un
je le vois dans vos yeux
je t'aime tellement tellement fort ma
chérie
nous avons quelques questions à vous
poser
d'accord
où étiez-vous la nuit ou lillibridge a
disparu
même si je te présente lily lilies lucie
fly alors tu es au japon depuis combien
de temps ça fait environ trois semaines
maintenant
c'est bizarre comment tout le monde nous
fixe au japon c'est comme si on était
ses lèvres
[Musique]
certains deviennent accros à ça
vous n'êtes pas comme tout le monde
vous non plus
alors ne faisons pas semblant
tu prends tout en photo
bien sûr
d'un petit ami oui il est trop mignon
mignon vent d'accord il est superbe
il al'air obsédé parfois qu'est ce qui
te fait dire ça je connais les hommes
c'est un sacré numéro
on direct elle seule qui existe et puis
elle passe à quelqu'un d'autre et c'est
comme si tu avais jamais existé
qu'est ce que tu vois pour les rien s'il
te plaît
on a quelque chose que personne d'autre
ne pourrait partager
tu ne suis pas bien sûr que si
qu'est ce que tu racontes je sais ce que
je ressens
tu dois me faire confiance
salut la seule qui ait jamais vu qu'ils
étaient vraiment
jean pression tu va se passer quelque
chose d'extrêmement crève au nom du
peuple français
le premier conseil de guerre du
gouvernement militaire de paris a
reconnu que nommé dreyfus alfred
coupables du crime de haute trahison
la leçon à tirer du châtiment de dreyfus
est de montrer au monde ce que nous
faisons des traîtres
vous êtes désormais responsable du
renseignement écolo sac
si nous découvrons que dreyfus et pas de
traîtres je pense que nous devrions agir
rapidement dans l'intérêt de l'armée
pendu au colonel ça tombait trop symbole
du chef nous suivons leurs ordres je ne
veux pas d'une autre refusent ce n'est
pas une autre affaire dreyfus mon
général c'est la même
un dossier secret sur fréjus désormais
je m'en charge des personnes aimant ont
intercepté mon courrier je suis
constamment suivi
peux-tu prouver tout cela je voudrais
éviter un scandale c'est déjà un
scandale
devrait quitter paris quelque temps j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter monsieur
emile du temps là quelqu'un doit exposer
toute l'histoire en tant qu'officier
d'actifs je ne peux rien écrire là
dessus vous non
les moins 6 j'accuse le général mercier
de s'être rendue complice d'une des plus
grande dignité du siècle
la crise que génération d'avoir usé
trêve j'ai de la chance de les souder
les avoir étouffés
j'accuse expert en écriture d'avoir fait
des rapports frauduleux
traître quand une société on est là
elle tombe en décomposition
[Musique]
non
je sais qu'il est là quelque part
il n'est pas question vieille sans lui
on ne saurait même pas où chercher le
repos
[Musique]
elle n'a laissé aucune indication n'a
pas de plan mais de miettes de pain
qu'on puisse suivre m'a peut-être que si
peut-être même qu'ils sont là
[Musique]
alors les robinson
regardez de l'autre côté du miroir
[Musique]
c'est moi qui le retrouverait hockey
c'est ça il faut que je te parle de
quelque chose aussi les examens soient
pas mais c'est pas quand celle ci mais
tu vas pas mourir un césar 10 mois mais
qu'est ce que tu fous là ce matin dit si
je te quitte plus et complètement cinglé
mais bon ça va j'ai envie cette séance
que tu as envie de faire là vraiment
avant de mourir allez sur la tombe
d'albert schweitzer re lire proust
intégralement et oublier acheter une
corde pour le pendre
j'ai des goûts simples mois et ont passé
un buisson nul tu te dire un truc je
choisis un truc est l'hôte est obligé de
le faire je ne prends pas l'avion je te
préviens ça ici c'est pas la démocratie
et arbitres de négoce ou tuteurs la cfdt
mais je suis inscrit à la cfdt
ça va sans doute vous paraître fou
mais je ne me suis pas malade on est pas
mal alors fait c'est lui qui est malade
alors on fait quoi les corses en fait
quoi bah ça va la bringue la nouba la
siesta
un joli comment vas tu vous avez piccoli
ou quoi j'ai envie cette avance que tu
as envie de faire et ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble
j'ai le droit de savoir ça fasse rire a
recours à c'est pas ta vie arthur et sa
vie
n'importe quoi
vous étiez là
sur ce que des cépages aurait du mal à
imaginer qu'on aime
et où la chine pour être avec césar
c'est très beau a pas l'impression qu'on
a l'air content ouais mais de combien à
billets
[Musique]